you know it's funny because you've been
not just in in your professional career
you've been very busy you you had your
second child since i saw you last is
that right yes yeah yeah she's three and
a half now okay i wonder if you get the
same question i get because we both have
reddish hair and everybody assumes that
my kids would automatically have red
hair neither of my children has red hair
in fact i was the only kid of my six
siblings to have red hair so yeah so it
was kind of because it's a squirrely
gene it shows up and then it disappears
you know it's a mutation it's a mutation
thanks a lot i mean
it can happen to anybody but i think sin
is involved yeah
yeah i mean my my redhead lineage is
very strong i come from
two sets of grandparents they were both
redheads on both sides right then both
my parents are redheads yes then myself
and my three siblings are redheads oh
and then my kids are blonde yeah they're
all so blonde yeah i just feel like i've
failed because you know
we are dying out we're going extinct yes
we are the redhead is going extinct
well did your kids get the fair hair and
the freckles
you know what they also didn't get those
they're they have these like golden tans
which is maybe maybe my children have
been spared right away because yeah
red-headed children we just can't help
but have lots of freckles and frizzy
hair and buck teeth why do we all have
buckets i don't know and we bur our skin
gets burned if we go near a french fry
sun lamp you know
it's just there's no way around it yeah
and then it peels and then it just turns
to lots of freckles now you have i
wonder why this sturdy lot is dying out
look at you look at andy over in the
corner there with his blonde hair right
germanic features laughing at us
yes you will soon be gone
you're you know it's a
little strange for you because you've
had such a good career and you are so
well known but you get mistaken for the
actress jessica chastain yeah these days
and i'm just curious and and in fact
um we have a still i believe a picture
of jessica says saying but do people
come up to you on the street and say hey
i love you jessica chastain you have to
oh yeah all the time only only when i'm
looking presentable and i have makeup on
when i look like myself nobody thinks i
look like jessica chastain right yeah we
a fan posted a video online
about this phenomenon and uh we'll we'll
talk about it in a second it's really
funny but the
the uh let's show it first this is a fan
who made this completely on their own
put it online and it went viral take a
look
everywhere i go i hear them whispering
wondering isn't that her yes that's
jessica chested we were both in the help
yes but who did i play you don't know
it's a blur thanks to jessica chastain
all the critics once considered me a
highlight is this
[Music]
[Applause]
here's what's weird someone
someone made this on their own put it up
when it goes viral and many people think
that you made it that that's you singing
it's not just many people it's my
parents
and i cannot convince them otherwise
right they so yeah this video went up
like a couple days ago and one of my
friends sent it to me and they said oh
it would be fun if you did like a dub
smash where you know you you like lip
sync to the to the lyrics and so i did
that and then jess posted that on her
social media right and so you know
there's something like inherently meta
about all of that so i understand the
confusion because i look like her and
i'm on her social media account saying
that i'm not jessica chastain that's
very confusing right and so i i called
my parents they they saw the video
someone sent them the video and they
emailed me and they said
it's genius that video is genius when
did you have the time to do it i it's
exactly your sense of humor
my dad emails me and he says um i showed
it to hanks and he thinks you are
brilliant
showed it to tom hanks tom hanks that's
great and so then i so then i called
them and i was just like
allow me to explain
i tried to articulate this to them on
email they just they didn't get it and
then you know after that was when i got
the hank's um email and and i said this
is not um this is not my doing
i did do the the dub smash you
understand what the word dub means
because they also thought it was my
voice they thought that was your voice
i know it's amazing too your dad is one
of the finest filmmakers in the world
but he's still a dad and doesn't get it
you know
and then and then he said and i was like
well you know and he was like oh yeah
hank's thought your voice was so
beautiful i was like well you you need
to tell him that it's not my voice he
said well i like him thinking that it
was your fault yeah see that's what
we're different if someone mistakenly
showed tom hanks something and he said
wow conan o'brien's brilliant and it
wasn't mine i'd be i'd say thank you
it was nothing tom little something i
did in my spare time okay let's talk
about jurassic world i saw the movie uh
the other day i thoroughly enjoyed it i
really feel like they've kicked this up
like seven notches and they didn't even
need to do that when you were cast in
jurassic world
did they because this is a big part of
being in one of these movies is you need
to be able to scream yes you need to be
able to scream as if you're seeing a
genetically mutated tyrannosaurus rex
chasing you
do they obviously
you're a very well known and respected
actor but did they check out first
whether you had a good screen because
that would be important yeah that would
be important they did not
they didn't that'd be so funny if they
committed to this 800 million dollar
movie hired you and you're terrific and
then you see the dentist and you're like
yeah the worst but i have to say they
they got lucky they took a good guess
you have a good screen you have a really
good scream i have a really good screen
do you mind if we come out can i is it
something you could do right now i can
do it right now okay um
to scare you
um yes
i'll be turned around okay i'm the
person you fear the most in the world oh
wait a minute okay i just realized i
have this
okay
[Applause]
[Music]
that made me love you uh yeah wow that
is uh painful that was really good it's
a hardcore scream was that would you
consider that like one of your main cool
secret powers that you have described
well yeah no i have i have this
screaming that i do and then there's
only i really only have one other trick
okay what's that
um i can i can cry
i can cry i can cry out of my eyes
um that's
wow
i think that's the best way yes yeah
yeah but um okay you can cry on command
yes really yeah i didn't i i okay that's
not something you could how long do you
need to prepare for that i mean i think
if we just like keep talking and
i don't know okay at some point i should
probably drink some water so that i'm
hydrated okay i mean if i just keep
talking to you you're going to start
crying at some point
okay dwight do we have to be talking
about things that are related to
jurassic world or just things in general
okay just be small talk it doesn't
matter you know what i like about home
depot is you can get
duct tape all kinds of duct tape you can
get gray duct tape yeah you can get
black
yeah i've gone home depot is huge right
i've gone to home depot many times
and i've bought all kinds of things i've
bought styrofoam i've bought
things that i could use to tape other
things together to other things i bought
uh piping uh i really like buying nails
and wood
i like buying
i was just wandering the aisles
sometimes buying all kinds of things at
home depot sometimes i'm there for days
i stay in the home depot for days and
days and days and days
and i just stay there and sometimes i
just wander the aisles all by myself
from home depot and i think about all
the amazing things that they have and i
think about all the incredible products
they have and i think about everything
that they have at home depot and i just
think to myself my god home depot how do
you do this
how do you do this incredible thing you
give so much and you get so little in
return i mean some people pay for the
stuff but they really paying you enough
for what it's worth they're not really
paying you what you really should have
and i think that at some point people
should actually give home depot what
they're do because it's not fair it's a
company it's in a company that should be
compensated
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
[Applause]
i think our producer was crying because
i think lowe's is a sponsor
[Laughter]
it lowe's are they the sponsor okay well
then all right well
close
it was a comedy bit lowe's doesn't make
us cry yeah we're so happy yes
[Applause]
that's their new slogan lowe's it won't
make you cry
that was absolutely fanta it was built
so beautifully i really uh wow i guess
that's a testament to my acting uh
i have a cousin who can do that but she
just used it uh used it to get out of
being busted for weed
when you're young and you cry it's like
all right get out of here
yeah yeah let's uh we have uh first of
all jurassic world i want to make sure
that i again say this is they've bumped
this up nine to ten notches uh it's it's
in 3d have you seen yourself in 3d do
you like yourself yes i saw myself twice
in 3d oh my god it's a little too close
for comfort yeah at first
and then you know and then there's
dinosaurs in 3d and then that's really
cool well we have a clip here from
jurassic world and i believe this is
where
the the billionaire
who has financed who owns everything
yeah and this is now 20 years later
jurassic park has become jurassic world
it's a huge success
and this is the billionaire you're
showing him your guy's newest creation
yeah the indominus rex for the first
time this is a t-rex that you guys have
has held a few mutually messed around
with yeah messed around with yeah okay
what's up with this clip from jurassic
world okay cool
was white
you know tournament was fined
think it'll scare the kids
the kids
this will give the parents nightmares
is that good
that's fantastic
[Music]
[Applause]
jurassic world
is in theaters friday
bryce dallas howard an absolute joy i
love talking to you you're so much fun
we'll be right back tony hale from veep